How do you feel about yourself? Are you proud of yourself? This is an inside game. If you want to
have more self-confidence, more self-love, more self-belief, it's about how do you feel about
yourself. Not what other people tell you, not what looks good on Instagram or YouTube. How do you feel
about yourself? People I think fall into two buckets. One, you'll have people who set really
small goals and then achieve them and then they get celebrated and you might feel good because
you posted that win on Instagram, you made a YouTube video and you can show off about how
great you are but really you know that you could have done more. You just set your sights way too
low, right? I use the example of running a race against three-year-olds. Great, you could win that
race against three-year-olds. You can do it. You can do it blindfolded. You could do it maybe even
crawling. Maybe. You can win that race pretty easily though and winning that race might get
you a little medal and you can post about on Instagram and show off how you won and you can
get all these accolades and people cheering you on that you know you're capable of more.